and then yeah you can go ahead and get
started
um so um welcome everyone uh
to another end of term um
uh uh conference presentation um
our speaker today is not known by most
of you
julian eggert who's a phd candidate in
the bioinformatics and computational
biomedicine major
julian received a bachelor of science in
bioinformatics with a minor in computer
science from the university of nebraska
omaha in 2014.
during his phd candidacy his primary
focus has been on applications
for studying genomics using dna and rna
sequencing
his research involves the use of network
inference approaches for characterizing
transcriptional regulation
and cellular differentiation and disease
so he's defending his phd dissertation
today so he's at the
very last step and
as usual uh everyone probably most of
you know the rug
um he will give his presentation um
we'll then open it to questions from the
public
um the the public the rest of us will be
dismissed leaving behind his
uh committee who may ask additional
questions and then he's dismissed and
the
committee wraps things up and comes up
with a determination whether he has
completed his dissertation so um go
ahead julian
all right uh yeah thank you bill uh so
as you mentioned my name is julian egger
and the title of my dissertation and
corresponding talk today
uh is network-based alternative splicing
signatures of drug response and aml
so just an overview of the key topics
that i'll be discussing uh first i'll
give a background
on alternative splicing and
transcriptional regulation
uh followed by an overview of a
methodology known as de novo
de novo network inference i will then
introduce my first specific aim of my
dissertation
which is to develop a framework for
characterizing coexpression of complex
alternative splicing variants in the
form of network modules
and i'll demonstrate this framework with
results from an initial use case
in which we characterize co-splicing
variation across human tissue types
and then in the final section of my talk
i will discuss the results of my
second specific aim which is to identify
co-splicing signatures of drug response
and acute myeloma
so alternative splicing is a process
that occurs during transcription
in which a single gene may produce
multiple distinct rna transcripts
so when a gene is first transcribed to
rna only specific segments of the gene
known as exons
are included in the final rna products
leaving behind the remaining segments
known as introns behind
and so alternative splicing refers to
the fact that the
specific set of exons included in the
final transcript may vary from transit
to
transcript as the gene is being
expressed so this may lead to the
production of
functionally distinct isoforms which in
turn
may lead to the production of
functionally and biologically distinct
proteins
and so the process of alternative
splicing uh serves alongside
gene expression as an important
regulatory mechanism for
numerous cellular functions including
specificity of cell types and
programming apoptosis and so when we
discuss alternative standpoint
um from a quantitative standpoint as you
hear as you'll hear me do today
uh we typically refer to the total
expression of each transcript relative
to the total expression of the gene
whereas when we discuss gene expression
we're actually referring to the
sum of expression from all the
alternatively spliced transcripts
that are being expressed
so this leads me to introduce the
central hypothesis of my dissertation
which is that transcription-wide
coordination of alternative splicing
uh influences therapeutic response in
acute mild leukemia
and so what do i mean in regards to
coordination
well in order to properly like uh
properly regulate cellular phenotypes
the process of transcription must be
highly coordinated and under
tight regulatory control across the
transcription
us for example if we look here
in a cellular differentiation process
known as hematopoiesis
stem cells undergo cellular
differentiation down specific lineages
to become various types of blood cells
and so this differentiation process
is driven by specific groups of genes
being either up or down
regulated in a highly coordinated
fashion
and hence they are undergoing what's
known as co-expression
in addition this cellular
differentiation process is further
driven by highly coordinated
changes and the relative expression of
alternative splicing variants
and is thus undergoing what is known as
co-splicing
so uh this is a this is a fairly well
studied process to an extent
uh the figure on the right is uh just
one for many studies characterizing
the number of genes and transcripts uh
that are being up or down regulated
through different stages of the lineage
now it's also important to note however
that if transcription is deregulated and
coordination is then lost
this can lead to the development of
various disease-related phenotypes such
as cancer
or is essential to be able to
comprehensively characterize
transcriptional regulation on a systems
level
in both normal and disease-related
biological systems
so how can we do this well given that uh
transcription occurs through a complex
regulatory network
we can study coexpression through the
use of what are known as gene
coexpression networks
where we infer a network of genes from
expression data
in order to characterize coexpression
patterns between genes
and be able to study how these genes may
interact with one another
so in a more traditional analysis of
gene expression
um we would actually just test every
detectable gene individually
to see if that any of the genes in our
data set have a significant change in
expression
between two phenotypes for example if we
were looking for differential expression
between two tissue types
or differential expression between the
control and the disease group
uh on the other hand gene co-expression
uh gene co-expression networks um they
allow us to study gene expression on a
systems level
and can allow us to better identify the
cellular pathways that
groups of co-expressed genes may be
involved in
now we do this of course uh under under
the assumption that gene uh groups of
genes do indeed cooperate within related
pathways and related cellular functions
so it's important to understand that uh
co-expression network studies are done
through what's known as de novo network
inference meaning that the underlying
structure of the network is unknown
and we must learn the network using gene
expression from the samples of our data
set
so using the data uh we infer uh we
infer relationships between
all uh possible pairs of genes using a
uh similarity measure such as a
basic sample correlation or a p or a
pearson correlation
we then store the pairwise similarities
in a symmetric adjacency matrix
and then we infer a network in which the
nodes represent our genes
and the edges of the network are based
on values from our inferred adjacency
and so this is an approach that's been
utilized on numerous occasions for
characterizing gene co-expression in
different systems
so what about inferring a network of
coordinated alternative splicing or
co-splicing
so inferring a network of co-splicing is
actually
far less straightforward than that of
gene coexpression
some of this has to do with the
biological biological complexity of
splicing
but this this also has to do with the
current state of rna sequencing
which is what we utilize for character
and
uh but nonetheless um there are a few
approaches that have been demonstrated
for
integrating splicing in new expression
networks
however um when i was thinking about the
requirements of a co-splicing network
inference framework in regards to
the specific biological questions that i
would want to ask
and that i would consider be as
meaningful there are a few aspects
missing uh from the previously
demonstrated approaches uh so
so what are they well um first off we
want to be able to characterize
co-splicing of what are known as
complex spicing variants and we want to
be able to formulate complex splicing in
a manner that's suitable for
a module-based approach of splicing uh
this would then allow us to
perform a module-based characterization
of co-splicing across different
biological systems
and would also allow us to identify
co-splicing modules that may be
associated
with one or more phenotypes of interest
uh so what are complex uh alternative
splicing variants
so first off um the intuitive approach
for
quantifying alternative splicing would
be to simply measure the expression
of each transcript that is being
expressed
however with the current state of rna
sequencing sequencing technology
that we use to sequence and measure
expressed rna from cell samples
the readout of rna-seq is in the form of
millions of short sequencing rates
that are much shorter than the exons
from which they were derived
and significantly much shorter than the
introns that separate the exotic
segments prior to splicing
so given that the alternative
transcripts will still share
a large number of exons after splicing
there's a relatively large of reed so
these black ribs right here
that will come from these shared exons
making it impossible to
distinguish the true transcriptive
origin for each reed
now in simple cases like we see in this
diagram
this is less of an issue but in many
cases of splicing the the splicing
patterns are actually extremely complex
as as is the case with this mdm2 gene
here at the bottom
and this is just the tip of the iceberg
in terms of how how complex the splicing
patterns can can undertake uh so looking
at this mdm2 gene
uh we see that we have a large cluster
of exons
that undergo selected usage in a very
complex manner
and methods that would then try to
estimate the full expression of the
transcripts from these splicing patterns
would be highly inaccurate
and then this would be especially
product problem trying to infer a
network so in a network standpoint
would be highly inaccurate and that the
inaccurate transcript estimation would
lead to spurious edges and essentially a
false network structure during the
inference approach
so previous co-splicing network
approaches
they've basically tried to mitigate the
transcript estimation problem
by focusing essentially by focusing on
the the expression of the individual
exons of the gene that will end up
varying across the gene due to splicing
it by their expression
so one approach is to just simply create
a network using the individual
exon uh however this introduces a large
amount of redundancy into the network um
along with the nodes of the network
having linear dependencies between
between those exons of the same gene so
other frameworks they've they've tried
to utilize what are known as aggregate
approaches in which they
essentially construct a network of gene
correlations based on the gene's
individual exon levels
these methods are effective for uh
giving us some uh
initial insights in in terms of how
co-expression may differ from
co-splicing but they have a few
drawbacks
um for one these methods don't uh
they don't fully capture the complexity
of the individual splice variants and
they don't
they're not even characterize the
coordination of the usage of these
complex splice variants and secondly
these aggregated approaches they also
don't allow for
a straightforward approach to quantify
splicing at a module level so we can
perform a module-based network analysis
uh and so what is this uh module-based
approach that i keep mentioning
well in a module-based network inference
approach after we infer a coexpression
network
we then perform a community detection
procedure in order to identify
sub networks of highly highly connected
nodes of the network or genes of the
network
which we ultimately call modules so
we can then take all the genes from a
given cluster and we can summarize their
expression to the module level in the
form of just a single value
this allows us to characterize
relationships between modules
representing groups of highly
co-expressed genes
and also allows us to identify modules
that may be
highly associated with particular
phenotypes of interest
and so why do we do this well from a
technical standpoint
this serves as a data reduction
technique so we know dem
we know that dimensionality reduction is
an extremely useful tool in the field of
genomics
and by creating a network of modules we
can reduce the size of our network which
would could be
made up of thousands of genes down to a
network that consists of maybe one
only one or two dozen modules however
this is also this is also extremely
useful from a biological perspective
uh given that we know groups of genes
undergo coordinated changes in
expression
and that they interact within specific
pathways to drive specific cellular
functions
and characterizing that network modules
in relation to phenotypes
allows us to identify the pathways that
are involved and allows us to study
their most central components
so this is an approach that's been
that's been utilized on numerous
occasions for studying gene coexpression
uh for example looking at the figure on
the right this is from a module-based
network
inference approach uh using samples from
different subtypes of breast cancer
and the authors of this paper uh they've
actually annotated uh the modules based
on their functions from a pathway
enrichment analysis so looking at the
bottom we have
um the 11 modules that they inferred
from a network consisting of thousands
of genes
and then taking these modules the
authors then modeled the expression
of each module against the different
subtypes of breast cancer
and essentially this this heat map is
essentially indicating uh which modules
are being up or
down regulated in the different subtypes
so for example if we look at this uh
first module on the left the ah which
the authors annotated as being involved
in estrogen
signaling we see that this module
is significantly upregulated in the
luminal a subtype
uh it has moderate expression levels in
normal-like and luminal b subtype
and is significantly down-regulated in
the basal subtype
and so what this might be indicating are
specific pathways that could essentially
be turned on or off
in different cell types or in different
conditions
so try to util trying to utilize modules
for co-splicing inference motivated my
first specific game
which was to develop a module-based
network approach to study the
co-expression of complex alternative
splicing variants
so in order to develop such an approach
uh we need the methodology
uh right that provides a comprehensive
representation of splicing
given the current limitations of
short-reach sequencing technology
uh so here at the top uh we have all the
possible exons that may be expressed uh
for a given gene during transcription
and in a typical rna-seq experiment we
would take all the reads from a giving
sample
from a given sample and we would align
these reads to a reference genome
here i've uh i've zoomed in on exon six
seven and eight
showing how the alignment of these reeds
uh might look after a line
for the kind of stuff is done so first
off um
notice the size of the reeds uh relative
to the size of the exons
and also notice the size of the exons
relative to the size of the introns
keeping in mind that i've actually
flipped the scale
for visualization purposes so actually
the introns are actually much larger
than the than the axons between them
also notice that most of the reeds here
in purple
align directly to the exons while a
small portion of reeds
are split across the intron regions
this is done by the spice aware aligner
during the alignment step
uh so these are called junction spanning
reads that are derived from the
uh from the end and beginning of exons
they
occur uh due to the fact that during
sequencing
we're actually sequencing rna after
splicing has occurred
and therefore these intron regions have
been removed from the final
rna transcript also notice that
some of the junction reads um from exon
6
are being connected to exon 7 while some
of the junction spanning reads connect
song 6
to exon 8. so what these rays indicate
is expression of transcripts being the
expression of transcripts that being
expressed
in which exon 7 is either included or
excluded from the different transcripts
so to characterize splicing of a gene we
can utilize these junction spanning
reads
to create what is known as a splicing
graph indicating
where alternative splicing of the gene
is occurring during transcription
so here we've made a directed graph
where the excellence of the nodes
and the junction spanning reads indicate
the paths along the graph
so this is from a single rna seq where
the numbers above all the edges
represent the number of reads that are
supporting a particular path
and so you'll notice the red and green
the red is
the red edges indicate splicing from
previously annotated transcripts
while the green they indicate novel
splicing that were
discovered during the alignment step
you'll also notice that
certain introns are colored red and
green these are a specific type of
alternative splicing that known as
retained introns the entire john is
retained in the transcript
so we construct our splicing graph using
exons and dropdown spanning reads
and then we can move through the
directed graph and anywhere that we have
a divergent path either
in going or outgoing we annotate it
in the form of what's known as a local
splice variant or an lsv
indicating where alternative splicing
has occurred
we can then quantify alternative
splicing using the lsv's from the graph
where for each of where for each lsv we
measure the relative usage of each
junction
using the number of number of reeves
that either support the inclusion or
exclusion relative to the total
expression of all the lsps junctions
and again so the reason that we do this
is to avoid the ambiguities when trying
to estimate the following transcripts
using short sequencing rates
so how can we incorporate these lsvs
into a network
well if you look at the graph um as i've
highlighted here
you'll see that many of the lsvs occur
within close proximity to one another
with many lsvs either sharing complete
junctions or sharing one or more exons
being represented by the lsv
uh so using this group of lsvs together
within the same network
would lead to a lot of redundancy and
also create edges within our network
that wouldn't necessarily be
biologically meaningful
given that they all come from the the
same genomic segment of the transcribed
rna
so what we can do and and what i've
proposed for this approach
is we can group all of the lsv's uh that
i
that have either fully or partially
overlapping uh
junctions and exons into what i call a
into what i call splice variant regions
or svrs
we can then represent the splicing of
all the lsvs within a given svr as a
single value
uh using what's known as singular value
decomposition which is the
uh used data reduction technique
so for example if we look at this
cluster and we call uh this cluster svr1
we see that this cluster has five ella's
fees that are all overlapping each other
since each lsv will always have at least
two or more junctions
we select the junction having the
greatest variability across our data set
we can take the splicing values of the
five lsvs from
all of our samples in our data set we
perform singular value decomposition
and we can then represent the splicing
value of the svr using the first
uh using the first eigenvector uh or the
leading
eigenvector which is equivalent to
taking the first principal component in
a
principal component analysis or a pca
so then we can use these svrs as
features during network inference
which will then be the nodes in our
co-splicing network
so to evaluate this framework um i
performed an initial analysis
with the goal be uh with the goal being
to see how well this approach can be
used to
characterize co-splicing modules across
human tissue types
and see if the results of the analysis
make sense biologically
based on based on what we understand in
regards to tissue specificity
uh so to understand the results it's uh
it's important to
be able to understand the network
inference steps uh prior to
the network analysis so first we're
going to formulate svrs using rna-seq
data
from the genotype tissue expression
project or gtex
which is a large consortium of omix data
from dozens of human tissue types
and so here i've selected 10 to 10
different tissue
types with six tissues being from
different brain regions and two
tissues being from two different heart
tissue types
and then we also have tissues from lung
tissue samples from lung tissue and we
also have samples from skeletal muscle
tissue
and so here we have some tissues that
are distinct but are still highly
related
along with other tissues that we expect
to be more differentiate
more differentiated from other tissue
types
so using the svrs from each group of
tissue samples
will then infer co-splicing networks for
each tissue separately
so this will leave us with 10 distinct
networks however each network will still
contain the same nodes
but the but the network edges will all
be independent
we'll then identify a set of consensus
modules consisting of nodes that are
highly co-spliced across
across all the ten tissue types and then
we'll use these modules for our analysis
so here uh we've inferred our 10
co-splicing networks
uh each heat map on the left represents
the adjacency matrix of network edge
ways for each tissue
and then we want to identify groups of
splice variants that are highly
connected across all the tissues
so we compute a consensus matrix using a
minimum quad
a minimum quantile approach where the
strength of the edges in the consensus
matrix
are based on essentially based on how
consistently heavy they are across
all the networks we then subtract the
edge weights from one
which is why the colors have been
inverted and we use the node distances
to perform clustering and identify
modules uh within our consensus network
we can then keep track of the modules in
our network by labeling by labeling
these modules using arbitrary color
assignments
uh so here's our consensus module set
so you'll see that we've reached the
size of our network
from about 4 100 svrs to just 13
co-splicing modules
we can summarize the uh the splicing
value of each module by performing
singular value decomposition
using all the all the nodes from one
module
in a similar basically in a similar and
basically representing the module using
the first principal component
which is similar to what we did when we
formulated svrs from all the lsv's
we then clustered the modules for each
tissue forming tissue-specific module
networks
and we can also cluster the modules
using all the tissues simultaneously in
order to create essentially a
consensus hierarchy which we can use as
a reference when we characterize the
intermodular differences across the
tissues
and so looking at the different networks
we can already start to see some of the
tissue specific differences
um in terms of the hierarchical
organization of the code splicing
modules
uh so the uh for the sake of time i'm
only going to summarize a couple of the
key results from the tissue analysis
uh so if we take a closer look at
inter-module variation
uh here i've selected three uh three of
the tissue networks used as an example
so we have
two brain networks hippocampus and
cortex
and we have one heart region uh atrial
appendage
and so going diagonal uh we see the
tissue specific module networks
however the modules are uh the order of
the modules are all in the same order
based on the consensus module dendrogram
so the heat maps at the bottom left they
indicate the preservation of all the
edges between two networks
and this is based on this versa this
first equation on the right
and so we can see that the edge weights
are more are
much more preserved between the two
brain regions and are less
are still preserved but less preserved
in certain modules
between the two brain regions and the
heart region
now the bar chart in the upper right up
here
they represent the preservation of the
module connectivity between two networks
the module uh where essentially module
connectivity is essentially the sum
of all the edges connected to a given
module and the preservation of this
connectivity is given
here in the second equation here on the
right so if we look across the bar
charts and we look at
preservation of model connectivity we
see across networks we see
pretty high preservation of most of the
modules
with the exception is when we compare
the heart tissue to the two brain
tissues
we see that the module and the this
greenish yellow module
the preservation of that connectivity
starts to decrease
and here's where we start to see some of
the differentiation of the intermodular
connectivities
between the two tissue types
sorry about that and then finally this
last
equation here at the bottom this is a
density preservation measure which is
essentially a
summarization of the total connectivity
of all the modules and the preservation
of the connectivity of all the modules
across the different networks
so that's represented by this d value up
here and again we can see that we have
high overall network density
preservation between the two brain
networks
and that preservation of density begins
to decrease uh as we compare the brain
networks to the
to the heart region so keeping this
density preservation in mind now we can
see the
uh here here the density preservation
values now across all the 10 10
all 10 of the tissue networks i've also
performed clustering using these values
where the
preservation was converted to a distance
and then so looking at the heat map and
the clustering results
we can see that the related tissues
exhibit higher preservation of
intermodular network characteristics
and so for example if we look in the
upper left corner we can see that the
brain regions all have greater
similarity to one another
and as we start to move away the
preservation begins to decrease
into the other two types and compare the
brain regions to the other tissue types
here we can see that the co-splicing
modules are enriched for numerous
cellular functions
uh so these are the real uh the results
uh showing the number of enriched gene
ontology terms for each module
based on the genes from which the splice
variants within the module were derived
uh so modules may share uh several
different go terms
so yeah they may share several different
go terms however
all the modules also contain their own
amount of significant arrangement for
what would be module specific terms for
example
some of the most significant module
specific terms uh are in the case of the
green module which is highly enriched
for one signaling
we see that the blue module is enriched
for apoptosis and the black module is
enriched for immune response
so we can also characterize the splicing
level of the modules in relation to
phenotypes so here
are we'll select our phenotype of
interest being different tissue groups
and so this heat map shows the splicing
value of each module
with samples grouped by tissue group and
we can see that the modules
exhibit tissue specific splicing
differences between
all the different tissue types so the
heat map at the bottom
shows adjusted p-values from a
statistical test comparing the splicing
level of one tissue
against all the remaining tissues so for
example if we look at the
the purple module we see that the purple
module if we look at the brain samples
and the muscle samples
we see that the brain that the purple
module is significantly
down regulated in the brain tissue and
then it's significantly upregulated
in the muscle tissue so we can use this
as sort of a way to evaluate how well we
can capture phenotypes
at the module level
so just to kind of quickly summarize the
uh co-splicing across human tissues
analysis
so here we i showed that related tissues
exhibit similar intermodular network
characteristics
and that these co-splicing modules are
enriched for known cellular functions
and they also contain teaching specific
splicing levels
so this all serves as a proof of concept
for a demonstration of this framework
uh for doing a module-based network
inference of complex bison variation
okay so moving on to my second specific
aim uh which is the key biological
question of my dissertation
uh my second aim is to characterize
co-express splicing variants in aml
and identify network-based splicing
signatures of therapeutic response
so acute my leukemia or aml is a cancer
of my lip blood cells in which
genetic changes occur in hematopoietic
stem and progenitor cells
causing abnormal proliferation
a system turn leads to accumulation of
leukemic cells within the blood
now these genetic changes they can occur
in the form of either large cytogenic
events or small gene mutations
and as a consequence uh these genetic
events lead to a loss of transcriptional
coordination during hematopoiesis
and leads to the development of the
cancer leukemia cell phenotype
so the long time uh standard of
treatment for an aml
uh has been chemotherapy uh often
accompanied by hematopoietic stem cell
transplants
um aml patients however um they're
likely to
relapse uh to eventually relapse after
initial treatment and develop into a
more aggressive form of cancer
over the last several years however the
use of targeted therapy approaches have
been developed
in which drugs are used to target the
specific mutations or
pathways that are being affected during
aml development so these can be used
alongside chemotherapy
or perhaps they can they can also be
used as an alternative to standard
standard chemotherapy for patients who
might be deemed unfit for
standard chemo uh so despite promising
results um there's still
a lot of variability um in terms of how
patients respond to these different
targeted therapy approaches
and this has to do with uh what is the
major challenge of anal therapy
development
and that aml is characterized by a
highly heterogeneous genomic landscape
in which we see mutational events from
over a thousand genes across different
aml patients
with each mutation that we see in cnaml
being present in only a small portion of
patients
and so each patient will typically have
maybe one or two dozen
of all these potential mutations
so my overall goal is basically to try
and characterize
some of the transcriptional mechanisms
in terms of splicing
that might be promoting the therapeutic
resistant phenotypes that we see in the
pima cells
and so with this network analysis what
we want to try and do
is try and identify co-splicing modules
that may be predictive of drug response
and number of targeted therapies
uh so i'm using data that's from the
baml cohort
which is a large collaborative aml
research program led by ohsu
it consists of a variety of data types
from aml patients including
cyber genetic profiles mutation calls
from whole exome sequencing
rna-seq data which i've used for
quantifying splicing variants
and it also contains drug response data
from cell viability assays from over 100
different targeted therapy types
okay so this is our co-splicing module
and
we started with a network consisting of
over 8 200 svrs
and we perform network clustering to
reduce the size of the network down to
13 co-splicing modules
so in a uh in a typical so
the modules are going to be what we're
going to use to uh as features to look
for
uh correlations with drug response
and then typical module phenotype
significant analysis
um in a typical analysis we could simply
just calculate the correlation of each
model
with to our trade of interest
in this case however we need to account
for the presence of the various genetic
events
that we already know to have pro
significant prognostic implications
and that we know are functionally
relevant in terms of
patients response to treatment and so
therefore we need to model the
co-occurrences
of both mutational events and changes in
splicing
and so we can use lasso regression which
is a linear regression technique that
uses l1 regularization
or shrinkage and lasso tries to reduce
the number of features in the model
by shrinking by shrinking non-predictive
feature coefficients to zero
and then only keeping the predictive
ones um so lasso is essentially
an inherently a feature selection
technique
so for each drug that we're modeling
we utilize lasso regression through an
iterative modeling technique
by splitting the samples into random
training and test sets
and then for each training set we
generate 1 000 random samples with
replacement of the same size
using the bootstrapping technique and so
for each bootstrap sample
train lasso regression using 10-fold
cross-validation
and then we repeat the procedure through
100 different iterations
uh selecting a new random training and
test set each time
finally we then record the frequency uh
to which each feature was selected as
being predicted
of drug response for a particular drug
by each lasso model
uh so so what does this kind of look
like um so first off so
we ran these lasso models for about 100
different drug types
and so here is a heat map showing how
predictive
each mutation or splice splicing module
is for a subset of for just a subset of
the drugs that we actually modeled
so there's a lot going on here so i'm
going to walk everyone through it
so the rows of the heat map represent
the iterative lasso models for each drug
and then the columns they represent the
features that were used in the lasso
regression models so all these features
were used together
in the last regression models for
modeling against drug response of a
given drug
now there's no significant ordering to
the
ordering of the columns but i've
separated the splicing modules to be on
the left and the mutations to be
stored on the right and so the mutations
are binary features it's essentially
just uh whether
a certain gene would had a positive or
negative call for having a mutation
and then so the values and intensity
the color intensities of each cell uh
they represent the frequency
as to which the lasso model the lasso
model selected that feature
as being predictive for a given drug so
it's it's the
it's the frequency of that feature being
uh selected as predictive
across our 1000 lassa models uh for each
drug
so we can actually just interpret these
essentially as a correlation
values and so they're basically
correlation values in regards to
response for each drug
uh it's just that it's done in a more
sophisticated manner in which
correlation speech feature
also takes into account the correlations
of the other features of the model
you'll also notice some columns have n a
so columns with n a
uh in the mutations group they just
indicate mutations um that were not
included in each module
uh due to a lack of positive mutation
calls and samples having drug response
data for a given drug
so with all the samples that we use to
build the network not all those samples
necessarily had drug response data for
every drug
so that's why we see some n a uh some n
a values for some of the mutations that
were included
looking through this heat map if you
look at the group of mutations one of
the
one of the columns that we first start
to see light up uh is the flit 3 itd
or the foot 3 internal tan duplication
and so we already know flip 3 flip 3 itd
as being
one of the most significant genetic
events um in terms of both patient
prognosis
and response rates to a variety of
targeted targeted therapies
however the the novel findings of this
analysis
of this analysis occur here where we see
a small group
of co-splicing modules that we can see
are being highly correlated
with response to a variety of different
drug types
and so the the the select drugs that
you're seeing here in this heat map
these are the drug models in which at
least one splicing module
had a correlation of at least 0.7 or
greater for
drug response for a given drug and so
looking here on the left we can see that
the tan module is the
most predictive module for around a
dozen of these inhibitors
however we also see that the blue module
the green module and the same module
also have
reasonably high correlations for a few
other drugs
and uh the correlations of these modules
we find that they're predictive for drug
response
and then they almost always occur with
known recurrent mutational events that
have already been studied and that we
know to have functional relevance when
it comes to therapeutic response
uh so for example um we say that the
tanco splicing module
is highly correlated with uh reasons
with uh resistance to the satinib
treatment
and it co-occurs with the cbfb myh11
fusion gene
as well as mutations in k-rasp ptp and
11 and tp53
we also have a few drugs nalotnib
rapomyosin and gdc0941
that are highly correlated with the tan
module
but as we can see in the in the mutation
section we see that the mutational
events may only have
just moderately correlations uh with
response outcomes so the
this is some cases where we're finding
that this the splicing may be more
predictive than
some of the mutations that we see
uh so our most uh significant
co-splicing module
in terms of drug response came from the
tan module
and its ability to predict uh response
to venetoclax
uh so here we're gonna we're gonna
select the nanoclass model for further
evaluation
and so here is a a more close-up view
of the modeling that was done for the
nether class response
using both mutations and splicing
modules and so the figure on the right
is a buzz saw plot
of our model coefficient frequencies um
where each colored segment indicates the
non-zero coefficient frequency
of the feature uh with respect to drug
response to venetoclax
and so uh starting with the tan module
uh the features go
clockwise from highest to lowest in
terms of their correlation to venetoclax
response
and then links between the segments they
indicate the frequency in which a pair
of features
were selected as being predicted by the
same lasso model
so for example we can see that changes
in splicing of the tanko splicing module
co-occurs with the presence or absence
of the pml rara fusion gene
as well as mutations of the tet2 gene
and the sf3b1 gene and so the
sf31 gene is a i should point out is a
splicing factor gene that acts as a
trans regulator for making splicing
decisions during transcription
we also see that the green module also
shows
at least minor correlations with
venetoclax response
uh but focusing more on the tn module uh
functional enrichment
of the tan module indicated that it's
enriched for numerous
numerous immune system-related pathways
including neutrophil degranulation
so neutrophils they're the most abundant
type of white blood cell
and they participate in in immune
response
and actually similar findings were found
in another study that was characterizing
gene coexpression modules along in a
similar approach like this alongside
mutations and found gene co-expression
modules also predictive of the nether
class response
and function functional enrichment of
those modules um showed that they were
also functionally enriched for immune
related pathways as well
i should also point out that um although
the tan module was not
specifically enriched for apoptosis
regulation
um from doing the pathway enrichment
analysis
uh looking a little more completely at
nodes within
the tan module i was looking at the
module hubs of the module which are the
uh the most
centrally connected nodes within the tam
module
and many of the splice variants from
these module hubs belong to genes that
are known to be involved in apoptosis
uh for example the shisa 5 gene and the
vert 2 gene
are two genes that are known to be
operational within the apoptosis pathway
and are known to interact with the tp53
tumor suppressor gene
and so what do i mention apoptosis um
well so venetoclax is a bh3 memetic
it targets the anti-apoptotic bcl2
protein
and as we know evading apoptosis is one
of the key hallmarks of cancer cells
and venetoclax it tries to inhibit bcl2
activity
in order to promote cellular death and
so patients treated with venetoclax
um they usually show good initial
response to treatment
but typically they will eventually
develop develop resistance to venetoclax
uh over time however we also do
we do see increased sensitivity within
out of class when it's observed in
combination with
other targeting agents
and so here as a visual reference i
think a subset
of the most centrally located nodes
within the tan module
and also some some of the most
essentially located nodes within the
green module which was also moderately
correlated to the metaclass response
and so using the splicing nodes i've
clustered the topmost sensitive and
resistant patient samples
and looking at this heat map we can
start to see some of the distinct
splicing signatures that are
distinguishing venetoclax resistant and
then
venetoclax sensitive patients
and so based on what we've seen in
previous studies
on gene expression and again what we're
seeing here uh with splicing
is that the leukemia cells are
developing resistance to venetoclax
therapy by essentially deregulating
apoptosis pathways and so what we're
seeing here within the splicing modules
might be that deregulation of
coordinated splicing decisions
in relation to apoptosis are further
driving therapeutic resistance
to treatment with phanetoglass
uh so i've demonstrated some interesting
results uh using this code splicing
network framework
um methods like these however they're
not without uh
potential limitations of course uh so
probably the most specific limitation
probably comes from the fact that
um our ability to infer co-splicing
networks
is dependent on our ability to
accurately quantify splicing uh
given the current state of the
quantification methods um so with the
graph
with the graph based method for
capturing confluence
uh these require the use of junction
spanning reads which
really only make up about 15 to 25
percent of our total read library
uh for a given sample this can depend on
the depth of sequencing and the the
length of those sequencing reads
from each sample it requires us to set a
minimum read threshold per
junction in order to conf confidently
estimate the junction usage
and if a sample does not meet the
threshold for a given lsp
it's essentially considered
unquantifiable and so
what i'm doing what i'm trying to
formulate svvs it requires that all the
lsvs
are quantifiable from all the samples
and the data set
and so in the analyses that i
demonstrated today we actually took a
fairly conservative approach
in which we only used lsv's for svr
formulation
if the lsp was quantifiable in all the
samples from the analysis
and so what the what this means is that
if just one
if just one sample in our analysis uh
didn't have sufficient coverage for
one of the lsvs that lsv is essentially
lost
in the analysis um
and what this might mean in terms of
functionality is that
um if we lose some of those fees and
then we don't
formulate svrs for these essentially
just means that that feature wouldn't be
included
in the the network inference analysis um
so this
could potentially lead to maybe a
potential loss of sensitivity
if there may be significant splice
variants that are that are really
significant towards your phenotype but
they just might not be included in
in the network analysis so there are
imputation methods
um imputation methods would try to uh
model some of the missing values these
have been used in coexpression network
studies based on microarray gene
expression data
these of course could have their own
issues if the imputations are
somewhat inaccurate and so really where
i think the the biggest future
directions are
in terms of this framework is just just
our ability to improve the modeling
of the splicing quantification and so
with the current approaches
you know we're able to you know actually
capture some of these
experience but we need um you know a
good amount of sequencing depth and
preferably longer reads and i think over
time as we improve the modeling of the
splicing quantification that will
improve our ability to infer grow spicy
networks
and also i think if we improve our
ability to quantify splicing for
unsupervised learning
um and so the methods like the the the
magic framework that i use to quantify
splicing funny splicing graphs
uh they're more specifically designed
for the two group analysis of splicing
work
similar to just doing uh differential
expression for the genes
where they essentially modeled changes
at the group level
between two groups of interest to see if
a splice variant has typically changed
uh change in usage
and so i think if we develop the methods
uh to be a little more supportive for
looking at the the splicing values of
the interval samples
and being able to use them more in an
unsupervised analysis
um given that uh de novo network
inference
um is essentially an unsupervised
analysis approach that will improve some
of our interference approaches
it'll also improve our ability to work
with large heterogeneous data sets
where they have variability in coverage
and we may have samples
that may be extreme outliers within our
sample code
so to summarize um i've demonstrated a
network inference
framework for co-splicing that can
include complex splicing variants in a
comprehensive
and non-redundant fashion with this
framework we can summarize splicing in
the form of modules and characterize
co-splicing modules across various
biological systems and phenotypes
and i provided results from a proof of
principle analysis
in which we characterize co-splicing
variation across human tissue types
and i showed that related tissues
exhibit similar network splicing
characteristics compared to non-related
tissues
and finally i demonstrated the results
of my second specific gain
finding co-splicing modules predicted by
drug response from multiple targeted
therapies
and we find that the splicing models
co-occur with mutations that are known
to have prognostic significance in aml
and the results of this aim may uh they
may be revealing intrinsic mechanisms to
which the cancer cells
may be obtaining drug resistant
phenotypes
and so before i close out uh i would
first like to thank my dissertation
advisory committee uh christina guaming
bob ted and shannon i especially want to
thank christina zhang who has been my
research advisor over the last five
years and has uh worked
excessively close with me on working on
this project
i also want to especially thank shannon
mcqueeney um for it was the day that i
met shannon
which was the day that i realized i need
to move to portland and attend ohsu
i want to thank my friends and family
especially my wife angela for all her
love and support
and i want to thank the demise students
faculty and staff for all their help as
well
and finally i'd like to acknowledge my
national library of medicine training
grant which funded my training
for my phd over the last five years and
with that
i'll leave it open for questions thank
you
great thanks thanks julian uh very nice
presentation
so uh we have some time for questions um
from the audience either um speak up or
in the chat box
any questions i i'm not sure if i can
see the chat box um
yeah no there's no questions in the chat
box
well i uh maybe everyone uh fully
fully understands
i hope so hey
hey julian um there was something on
uh slide seven i wanted to ask you about
slide seven
okay you just hold it up
uh
yeah i'll do it sorry yeah just a second
no worries
yeah i wanted you to explain that thing
called the adjacency matrix
um a bit more to me
yeah so um this is how we infer the the
network structure so
you know as we know so so the nodes of
the network um would be genes or myclase
or splicing variants and we don't know
the the underlying structure of the
network so the
essentially these edge waves like how
strong all the relations of
relationships of the genes are between
the nodes of the network
so we need to infer that information and
so what we do is we use the expression
data so
here's like an example of what the
sample data might look like and actually
we would have you know
thousands and thousands of genes and
maybe hundreds of samples
so we need to refer basically pairwise
relationships
between all the possible edge waves so
the adjacency matrix is
it's a it's a symmetric matrix of all
the genes or
network and so basically for every pair
of genes
we try to infer a relationship so kind
of like
the most simple kind of straightforward
way that's commonly used is basically
just to use like a correlation so we can
use like a pearson correlation
and we see like as gene one how
correlated is gene one with gene two
and that then serves as sort of the
initial value in the adjacency matrix
uh so that's just a bit there's actually
a lot of ways to kind of compute pearson
uh compute
similarities i actually used a different
type of uh correlation measure called by
wave mid correlations
and then what we could do is um you'll
also notice that there's actually
negative values in here
so it's it doesn't necessarily make
sense to have negative values in the
network at least for at least for this
approach
um so usually we do some sort of
transformation so we can actually
um in my case i created what's known as
a as a sign network
where i actually scaled uh the values
were the
negative correlation so if it's a
correlation of negative one we scale
that to zero
the correlations of one stay at one and
correlations of zero go to zero point
five
um so just shift so basically it
promotes the positive correlations and
then the negative correlations would be
considered weak correlations
but this essentially is it represents
the the weights of the edges
and the network we can also use a
different approach where we may put a
threshold on the correlations
and there's different ways to do this
where we could just create a binary
network and we only include edges if we
have strong enough correlations
uh does that answer your question yeah
very good thank you
yeah okay anybody else
any other questions
great well if not um we can um
excuse the public myself included and
leave you behind with your committee who
likely has